the PlayStation 5 gets a price increase
in some regions lies of P gets a meaty
new Gameplay trailer and Battlefield
2042 second season details are revealed
Sony interactive entertainment is
increasing the price of the PlayStation
5 across various regions citing adverse
currency Trends and global economic
challenges as their primary reason Sony
interactive entertainment CEO Jim Ryan
stated in a blog post that the price
increase is going to affect all of
Europe the UK the Middle East Africa
Asia and parts of North America due to
the current strength of the dollar the
United States will not be affected by
the change the price increase seems to
be about 10 percent across the board
Ryan states that Sony's top priority is
lessening the strain on the supply chain
for PS5 production to keep the console
in stock across all regions except for
Japan the new pricing model is effective
immediately there is no indication as to
whether Microsoft will increase the
price of the series X but there is
speculation that they might use this
decision by PlayStation to promote the
series s and Game Pass programs Nintendo
previously stated that the switch will
remain the same price in case anyone was
worried
Liza P the latest entry in the
soulsborne genre got a six minute
Gameplay trailer after being shown off
at Opening Night Live based on the tale
of Pinocchio this steampunk Souls like
is sure to scratch that bloodborne itch
the gameplay looks to emulate that
feeling directly with attacks and
parries that also incorporate
Pinocchio's mechanical arm to shock or
grapple enemies swords Hammers and
shields are your primary tools for
bashing Baddies
the systems also show off a
decision-making mechanic based on lies
that could factor in how you are able to
navigate the world and NPC encounters
the boss fights look to fall right in
line with the games they are inspired by
with large-scale automatons dealing
massive amounts of damage if you aren't
careful developer neowiz has not set a
hard and fast release date but expect to
explore the desolate world of lies of p
in early 2023. as a fan of the early
1900s aesthetic in games like BioShock
Infinite I am super excited to explore
the creepy World's Fair gone wrong
worlds of lies of p and if you want to
check out that Gameplay trailer head
over to gamespot.com or our YouTube
channel
EA and dice have announced the first
details of Battlefield 2042's second
season the season called Master of Arms
is set to release on all platforms on
August 30th Battlefield portal also gets
new features as well the new season adds
a new map set called Stranded as well as
a new specialist character more weapons
and gear and a new battle pass with 100
tiers of content
in the new map called Stranded players
will be able to fight for control of a
ship and can go inside for Close
Quarters combat we're also seeing the
addition of a Healer and support
specialist who can revive and refill
gadgets and he also has a minigun
additionally season 2 unlocks a new
feature called assignments in which
players can unlock weapons and gear that
were only previously available in the
battlefield portal
well that's all the news we have for
today thanks for tuning in and for
everything video game related keep it
here at GameSpot